ni pro compte toujours ses morts le
bilan des victimes de l'attaque russe
n'est toujours pas définitif pendant que
les secouristes découvrent de nouveaux
corps dans les gravats habitants et
associations locales se mobilisent pour
les survivants
nous avons aidé à fournir les premiers
soins et une assistance psychologique
aux personnes secourues et tout de suite
après l'explosion nous avons installé
cette tente qui fonctionne en continu 24
heures sur 24
l'immeuble de 75 appartements a été
touché de plein fouet par un missile
plusieurs étages ont été détruits dans
l'explosion qui a aussi touché les
immeubles voisins certains habitants
viennent désormais récupérer des
affaires et espèrent que leur partie
intacte de l'immeuble ne sera pas rasé
l'ONU rappelle que cette frappe est
l'une des plus meurtrières contre des
civils depuis le début du conflit et
qu'elle ne doit pas faire oublier que la
guerre se poursuit ailleurs dans le pays
ce n'était pas la seule attaque contre
des civils en Ukraine ce weekend à
Herson par exemple les locaux abritant
la société ukrainienne de la Croix-Rouge
ont été touchés hier lors d'un
bombardement dans la ville bien que
personne n'ait été blessé l'organisation
a perdu des équipements essentiels
les Nations Unies dénoncent une
suspicion de violation du droit de la
guerre la présidente suédoise de l'Union
européenne accuse plus directement
Moscou de crime de guerre comme à son
habitude la Russie a démenti être
responsable de la frappe et va même
jusqu'à évoquer une tragédie